okay so in this video we're going to
look at the process of meiosis as it
proceeds through a diploid human cell so
let's go ahead and get started
so here we have a cell prior to prior to
meiosis in the stage of interphase and I
want to put a note in the upper left
hand corner that notice that there are
46 strands of DNA 46 strands of
chromatin in this cell because this is
the human diploid amount of DNA that is
better in cells so if we actually just
do a quick count just to make sure that
I'm not making any of this up we're
counting through and we are finding 23
in black 23 strands of DNA in black this
represents the black color represents
paternal DNA DNA that you inherited from
your father
and right now the red strands of DNA are
being added up these are the maternal
strands of DNA notice how there are 23
maternal strands of DNA in red plus the
23 paternal DNA strands in black that's
how we know there are 46 strands of DNA
in this cell just like in human diploid
cells so as we move into the s stage of
interphase notice what happens is the
chromatin is copied and duplicated so
the 46 strands actually duplicates to
form 92 strands well now we head and
enter into meiosis meiosis number one
there's meiosis one and there's a
myiasis - there's two rounds of cell
divisions in meiosis so let's start with
prophase number one of meiosis number
one so the nucleus will dissolve and
what happens next is the chromatin will
coil into chromosomes and I've numbered
them if you look closely there are two
chromosome threes one in black one in
red there are two chromosome 12 one
in black one in red there's two of each
chromosome number one in black one in
red and during the process of synapses
these chromosome pairs these homologous
chromosomes will pair with one another
so notice what's happening here are the
two chromosome sevens are drawn next to
each other the crew two chromosome twos
are grouped next to each other the two
chromosome fives are grouped next to
each other these form groupings of what
are called tetrads there's one tetrad of
made up of two chromosome sixes there's
another tetrad made up of two chromosome
11s and there's another tetrad made up
of two chromosome 15 so there's 23
tetrads I've just highlighted three of
them so why does this happen why does
synapses occur well synapses will set up
what's called crossing over and if we
focus on the tetrad number two here
let's zoom on in and take a closer look
at these two chromosomes so what happens
during crossing over is that enzymes
will actually break off portions of the
maternal and paternal chromosome and
rearrange them so if you notice you have
a mostly black paternal chromosome with
a small piece of red maternal DNA on it
and then same with the red chromosome
the red chromosome is made up of mostly
red maternal DNA and genes but there's a
small piece of black paternal DNA in
jeans attached to it so when we come
back to our cell here we can now zoom
into let's say tetrad number six here
and let's let's examine crossing over
with tetrad number six so like we saw
before enzymes will rearrange and
recombine a little bit of the maternal
and paternal DNA during the crossing
over period and let's highlight one more
tetrad let's highlight tetrad number one
and let's zoom on in one last time
so during crossing over again portions
of the maternal and paternal chromosomes
are rearranged with one another
this creates genetic diversity and this
genetic diversity is created in all of
the tetrads watch the remaining twenty
tetrads they all experience crossing
over and this is what leads to the
genetic diversity that we see in cells
created by meiosis so now that we're
done with prophase number one we're
moving into metaphase number one and
what happens is the tetrads will be
aligned along the equator of the cell
you might know that there are threads of
proteins called spindle fibres that will
attach themselves to the chromosomes and
the spindle fibers will pull the tetrads
to the equator along the equator or the
middle line of the cell well this takes
us to anaphase number one the spindle
fibers will pull the chromosomes apart
splitting the tetrad you know one
chromosome of the tetrad was pulled to
the left and the other chromosome of the
tetrad was pulled to the right and so as
we move on to telophase number one
cytokinesis will divide the one cell
into two cells and sometimes even the
nucleus will reform now just for the
sake of this on this animation I showed
the nucleus reforming sometimes it does
sometimes it doesn't well now that we're
wrapping up meiosis number one we're
going to move into meiosis number two
and meiosis number two begins with
prophase number two so if the nucleus
reformed then it will simply just
rheda's all've
and as we move into metaphase number two
the chromosomes are once again going to
be aligned along the equator or the
middle line of the cell difference being
notice how it's not tetrads anymore the
tetrads were separated during anaphase
number one so now it's just the
individual
homes that are aligned along the equator
of the cell and when we move on into
anaphase number two I hope you can
predict what's going to happen we know
that one chromosome is made from two
halves called chromatids so the
chromatids are going to be pulled to
opposite ends of the cell one chromatid
of a chromosome was pulled upward one
chromatid of the chromosome was pulled
downward by the spindle fibers and so as
we near the end we come to telophase
number two cytokinesis divides the two
cells into four cells the chromatids
will uncoil into the loose linear
strands of DNA known as chromatin the
nuclei will reform in all four of the
cells and so when we're done here notice
what we have we have four genetically
unique haploid cells they're genetically
unique because we experience crossing
over earlier and they're haploid because
notice in the upper left-hand corner I
made a note in the upper left-hand
corner we started with cell with one
cell that had 46 strands of DNA but now
these cells that are created only have
23 strands of DNA and I'd like to prove
that to you right now so if we just look
at the cell on the top left I'm just
going to make start counting strands of
DNA there's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 strands
of DNA but the one cell we had at the
beginning had 46 strands but this cells
only got 23 same with the cell on the
top right same with the cell on the
bottom left same with the cell on the
bottom right so this is how meiosis
reduces the chromosome number in half
and creates haploid cells so that's the
end of this video I hope you enjoyed
this and I'd love to hear your comments
in the box below
thank you for watching